so far we've used integrals to figure
out the area under curve and let's just
review a little bit of the intuition
although this should hopefully be second
nature to you at this point if it's not
you might want to review the definite
integration videos but if I have some
function this is the xy-plane that's the
x-axis that's the y-axis and I have some
function let's call that you know this
is y is equal to some function of X you
give me an X and I'll give you a Y if I
wanted to figure out the area under this
curve between let's say X is equal to a
and X is equal to B so this is the area
I want to figure out this area right
here what I do is I split it up into a
bunch of into a bunch of columns or a
bunch of rectangles where let me draw
one of those rectangles where you could
view and there's different ways to do
this but this is just a review where you
could review that's maybe one of the
rectangles well the area of the
rectangle is just base times height
right we're going to make these
rectangles really skinny just sum up an
infinite number of them so we want to
make them infinitely small but let's
just call the base of this rectangle DX
and then the height of this rectangle is
going to be f of X at that point right
it's going to be F of if this is X
naught or whatever you can just call it
f of X right that's the height of that
rectangle and if we wanted to take the
sum of all of these rectangles right
there's just going to be a bunch of them
one there one there then we'll get the
area and if these if we have infinite
number of these rectangles that they're
infinitely skinny we have exactly the
area under that curve that's the
intuition behind the definite integral
and the way we write that it's the
definite integral we're going to take
the sums of these rectangles from X is
equal to a to X is equal to B and the
sum or the areas that we're summing up
are going to be the height is f of X and
the width is d of X it's going to be f
of x times d of X this is equal to the
area under the curve f of XY is equal to
f of X from
X is equal to 8 X is equal to B and
that's just a little bit of review but
hopefully you'll now see the parallel of
how we extend this to taking the volume
under a surface so first of all what is
the surface well if we're thinking in
three dimensions the surface is going to
be a function of f of X and Y so we can
write a surface as instead of Y is a
function of F and X I'm sorry instead of
saying that Y is a function of X we can
write a surface as Z is equal to a
function of x and y so you can kind of
view it as the domain right the domain
is all of the set of valid things that
you can input into a function so now
before our domain was just at least you
know for most of what we dealt with was
just the x-axis or kind of the real
number line in the X direction now our
domain is the XY plane we can given any
X and any Y and well we'll just deal
with reals right now but I want to get
to technical and then it'll pop out
another number and if we wanted to graph
it will be our height and so that could
be the height of a surface so let me
just show you what a surface looks like
in case you don't remember and we'll
actually figure out the volume under
this surface so this is a surface I'll
tell you its function in a second but
it's pretty neat to look at but as you
can see it's a surface it's like it's
like a piece of paper that's bent right
let's see let me rotate it to this
traditional form so this is this is the
X Direction this is the Y direction and
the height is a function of where we are
in the XY plane so how do we figure out
the volume under a surface like this
right how do we figure out the volume it
seems like a bit of a stretch given what
we've learned from this but what if and
I'm just going to draw an abstract
surface here let me draw some axes
let's say that's my x-axis that's my
y-axis to my z-axis I don't practice
these videos ahead of time so I'm often
wondering what I'm about to draw okay so
that's X that's why and that's Z and
let's say I have some surface some
surface I'll just draw something I don't
know what it is
some surface this is this is our surface
Z is a function of x and y so you give
me a coordinate in the XY plane say here
I'll put it into the function and it'll
give us a Z value and I would plot it
there and it'll be a point on the
surface so what we want to figure out is
a volume under the surface and we have
to specify bounds right from here we
said X is equal to a to X is equal to B
so let's make a square bound first
because this keeps it a lot simpler so
let's say that the the domain or the
region not the domain the region of the
X&Y region of this part of the of the
surface under which we want to calculate
the volume let's say it's let's say the
shadow we if the Sun was right above the
surface the shadow would be right there
let me try my best to draw this neatly
so this is what we're going to try to
figure out the volume of all right and
let's say let's say so if we wanted to
draw it in the XY plane like just you
can kind of view the projection of the
surface in the XY plane or the shadow of
the surface in the XY plane what are the
bounds oh you can almost view it what
are the bounds of the domain well let's
say that this point let's say that this
this right here that's 0 0 and the XY
plane let's say that this is Y is equal
to I don't know that's Y is equal to ay
that's this line right here Y is equal
to a and let's say that this line right
here is
X is equal to B hope you get that right
this is the XY plane if you have a
constant X it would be aligned like that
a constant Y aligned like that and then
we have the area in between it so how do
we figure out the volume under this well
if I just wanted to figure out the area
of a of let's just say this sliver let's
say we we had a well actually let go the
other way let's say we had a constant Y
so let's say for any I had some sliver I
don't want to confuse you let's say that
I have some constant Y now I just want
to give you the intuition you know let's
say I don't know what that is just an
arbitrary Y but for some constant Y what
if I could just figure out the area
under the curve there right how would I
figure out just the area under that
curve it'll be a function of which why I
pick right because if I pick a y here
it'll be a different area if I pick a Y
there it'll be a different area but I
could view this now as a very similar
problem to this one up here I could have
my DX is let me pick a vibrant color so
you can see it let's say that's DX right
that's a change in X and then the height
this height is going to be that height
it's going to be a function of the X I
have and the end end and and the y I've
picked right although I'm assuming to
some degree that that's a constant Y so
what would be what would be the area of
this sheet of paper right it's kind of a
constant Y it's it's part of it's a
sheet of paper within this volume you
can kind of view it well it would be we
set the height of each of these
rectangles is f of XY f of XY right
that's the height depends which x and y
we pick down here and then its width is
going to be d of X not D of X DX
and then if we integrated it from X is
equal to zero which was back here all
the way to X is equal to B what would it
look like it look like that X is going
from zero to be fair enough and this
would actually give us a function of Y
this would give us an expression so that
if it I would know the area of this of
this kind of sliver of the volume for
any given value of y if you give me a Y
I can tell you the area of the sliver
that corresponds to that Y now what can
I do if I know the area of any given
sliver what if I multiply the area of
that sliver times dy right this is a dy
let me do it in a in a vibrant color so
dy a very small change in Y right if I
multiply this area times a small dy then
all of a sudden I have a sliver of
volume hopefully that makes some sense
right I'm making that that little cut
that I that I took the area of I'm
making it three-dimensional so what
would be the volume of that sliver the
volume of that sliver will be this
function of Y times dy or this whole
thing times dy so it would be the
integral from zero to B of f of X Y DX
that gives us the area of this blue
sheet now if I multiply this whole thing
times dy I get this volume right it gets
some depth that this little area that
I'm shading right here gives death of
depth of that sheet now if I added all
of those those sheets that now have
depth if I if I took the infinite sum so
if I took the integral of this from my
lower Y bound from 0 to my upper Y bound
a then at least you know based on our
intuition here maybe I will have figured
out the volume under this surface but
anyway I didn't want to confuse you but
that's the intuition of what we're going
to do and I think you're going to find
out that actually calculating the
volumes are
are pretty straightforward especially
when you have fixed X&Y bounds and
that's what we're going to do in the
next video see you soon